hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to let's talk about
the film that made pedophilia upwork no
no the other overrated one there you go
American Beauty when are a five Academy
Awards including Best writer that's
Actor Best Director and Best Picture of
the year audiences nowadays can
naturally only think of one thing about
this movie 1999 must have been a very
slow year and yeah okay fair enough but
does this film deserve the backlash it's
getting hell
is it even a backlash people who watch
it today don't typically see it as great
but they don't necessarily see it as bad
either kind of sorta yeah that bag thing
is praised too but now isn't it
with that said there will be spoilers in
this editorial so heads up a bag is
filmed
needless to say for a while this film
was a pretty big deal everyone liked
talking about it and analyzing it even
though by today's standards all the
things to talk about are seen as pretty
heavy hand honking his clothes mean
she's materialistic the Red Door means
danger and or lust the flower petals
means obvious symbolism and so on and so
forth so what is it people saw back then
and should we dig deeper to see it today
a lot of the film centers around a dead
man talking about his midlife crisis
when he was alive he also somehow knows
scenes that happen with the rest of his
family even though he wasn't there but
you could just say that's ghost powers
or something it was a ghost
yeah what she said we mostly see typical
suburban Knights who have dreams and
passions lost to the system of the
status quo or wanting to fit in some
embrace the lifestyle but others are
restless and Venom one day our lead
decides he doesn't care anymore and is
going to do whatever he wants including
quitting his job getting high and yes
sexually chasing a high-school student
not only a student but a friend of his
daughter who also seems to be breaking
the mold by befriending a bizarre yet
poetic no no you have to see me why I
say poetic poetic see makes a difference
student who is also a drug dealer and
son to a homophobe this is not the first
film to indicate that middle America is
unhappy with what the American Dream
claims they should be happy with so why
did this strike such a strong chord well
first off its one of the few movies that
seems to address both older and younger
audiences and it did a pretty good job
speaking to both age groups and giving
them equal time second this truly was
during a time when many people felt like
they were part of the nothing generation
hell Fight Club came out the exact same
summer addressing the frustrations of
lacking a meaningful identity while been
raised on television to believe that one
day we'd all be movie gods and rock
stars but we won't but we're Fight Club
went to several extremes with this
message both visually and story-wise
American Beauty was a little calmer in
its approach it seemed to combine
somewhat corny emotional technique you'd
see and say a spielberger zemeckis movie
but added just enough of an edge to make
it feel a touch more personal its
imagery pretty its pace Comfort Li slow
and its actions direct but just artistic
enough so people can read a little more
into it and feel a sense of
accomplishment that they could even do
that because there's nothing worse than
life and be more
you know it's kind of like that person
who thinks they're into anime because
they saw spirited away it's a good start
but that's not exactly knowing anime
there's a bit more to it but back then
it was a nice feeling when people felt
they could be a little artsy every once
in a while even if it was very little
compared to other art house films
according to her I'm too focused on my
career highest as if being driven to
succeed is some sort of a character flaw
mm-hmm because of this people were a lot
more accepting of a man who is openly
pursuing an underage girl they
recognized him as doing wrong but at the
same time sympathize with what led him
to the state think about that
how many mainstream big hit film star a
pedophile as you're identifiable hero
until the characters credit he doesn't
go through with it he does wake up and
realize he was doing something that he
should have no part of but oddly enough
that's not what most people have issues
with in the movie the biggest argument a
lot of folks have is that it's
pretentious case in point the kid who
films everything and sees Beauty
everywhere especially claiming that a
dancing bag is the most beautiful thing
he saw sometimes there's so much beauty
in the world
like I can't take it yeah we bought it
in the film because there's nice music
and an obviously prepared speech but if
it happened in real life you'd probably
be afraid of this guy hell this could
just as easily be seen in a horror just
change the music up a bit like a little
kid begging me to play I need to
remember
sometimes there's so much beauty
no world
like I can't take it
the narration seems a little full of
itself too as if the film has all the
answers with how to make your life happy
you just don't see it yet and I can't
feel anything but gratitude for every
single moment of my stupid little life
you have no idea what I'm talking about
I'm sure but don't worry you will
someday that's a pretty pompous thing to
boast about when you get down to it but
at the same time you get the feeling the
film means well it doesn't indicate
there's necessarily good guys or bad
guys they're just people trying to find
their way so really it doesn't seem too
bad but nevertheless there's a reason so
many people have labeled this film as
uber preachy where many today see the
subject in tone as more
middle-of-the-road
at the time it was seen as kind of
daring or at least daring enough I'm not
for white suburban adults and high
schoolers to have a comforting outlet
for their growing insecurities in a not
particularly hostile environment so
should it be ignored is it just a
forgettable product of the times well in
my opinion yes em no it is a product of
the times but not one that should
necessarily be forgotten where something
like Fight Club keeps coming back
generation after generation because it
takes chances with his clever extremes
and what American elements would never
truly go away
American Beauty is distinctly what
middle-class America was thinking and
feeling at that time since then we've
had events like 9/11 the Iraq war the
economic crash and of course the
technological boom of online media and
portable devices
there's probably much more options now
more than ever for creating a distinct
identity it's not even that big an issue
anymore that is if there are other films
will probably tackle in the near future
but that's another issue
American Beauty has indeed become dated
but it's in the same way something like
Easy Rider is dated it's so rich in the
emotions of the time period it's
representing that it's actually kind of
intriguing
it's interesting to see what mainstream
audience is related to here and what it
says about when it was made where most
films we remember are timeless and live
on forever
this one grads one distinct bundle of
time and shows that not just in its
words but in its style many movies since
this had tried to capture the beauty as
well as the eeriness of pastel America
we've also seen the fed up suburban
night wanting to break the mold a lot
more after this film to a point where
it's almost become a cliche though passe
by today's standards American Beauty did
help give an identity to a lot of people
who were searching for one even if it
was just for a short period of time and
not just for adults but with younger
people too there were very few films
then and you can even argue now that
both high schoolers and middle aged
adults felt spoke to them on a personal
level like it knew what they were going
through at that very moment given the
difference in preference of both those
age groups
that's pretty rare whether or not it
will have an effect on you now it
certainly left an impact on us then and
allows for updated yet still fascinating
movie that has a strange Beauty
distinctly all its own yeah maybe a
product of the times but if you ever
wanted to return to that time this is
the interesting little time capsule to
do it with and that definitely has to
count for something
and is show the Thor breeches boobs that
that all account for something to not
let Nostalgia Critic I remember so you
don't have to
you